kim kardashian has that new crush
feeling when it comes to her romance
with pete davidson it's really lit and
and fun and crazy a source is opening up
to et about the 41 year old beauty mogul
and the 28 year old snl star's budding
relationship explaining that when pete
is around kim is giddy the source also
says quote kim feels relaxed and
comfortable with pete and she definitely
has that new crush feeling with him it's
always so much fun the reality star and
comedian first sparked romance rumors in
october after kim hosted snl i like you
just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
just days after the pair was
photographed holding hands while riding
a roller coaster at not scary farm and
since then they've been spotted on dates
in la palm springs and pete's hometown
in staten island i don't know where
these rumors come from so far kim and
pete have not officially confirmed their
relationship and pete's friends are also
staying mum
like his snl co-star alex moffitt i
don't really stay up to date with what
my good friend uh pete's up to as long
as he's having fun and he's happy that's
all i care about he's a love i love that
dude machine gun kelly was also
tight-lipped gotta ask you your boy pete
davidson and kim kardashian how happy
are you for him
as for kim who has filed for divorce
from her husband kanye west back in
february after six years of marriage e.t
has learned that just last week she
filed legal documents to be declared
legally single and to restore her maiden
name dropping west i'm married the best
rapper of all time
not only that he's the richest black man
in america a talented legit genius who
gave me four incredible kids
so when i divorced him you have to know
it came down to just one thing
his personality
and kanye well he hasn't been shy about
letting the world know he wants kim back
the grammy winner's latest move tweaking
the lyrics to his hit run away to shout
out his estranged wife during a benefit
concert in la last week
[Music]
and while kim and pete seemed to be
having a great time a source previously
told et that the mom of four is still
quote protective of kanye and his
feelings explaining that she's been
keeping her hangouts with pete loki
because she doesn't know how kanye will
react